Elixir hello everybody my name is
Markiplier and welcome to sinking iron a
game made by lixian featuring a cross
between iron lung and Five Nights at
Freddy's and if you watch Lexi in videos
he actually started making this game
before he even knew that I was making a
movie about it iron lung that is but
this is actually
um I saw his video come out literally
two hours ago but now I'm playing it so
I'm a little late being two hours after
release but I'm gonna play it anyway
a strong submarine earthquake caught the
attention of an amateur diver in his
Apprentice
they were close by when the incident
happened and decided to investigate
before officials arrived you are The
Apprentice good luck thanks I'll
probably need it
hi
rookie hey
stairs we're almost there
all right
you got it Captain I'm on the way
can I just jump down no I can't jump
that would be too easy
so uh this is Lexia knows I'm gonna be
hyper critical about every little oh my
God
10 out of 10. perfect game two thumbs up
five out of five Game of the Year
Edition
oh my God
oh my God I will not be swayed by
adorable animals I will judge this game
fairly
oh it's such a rip-off of being a cross
between iron lung and apparently Five
Nights at Freddy's or something like
that
[Music]
but what if I don't
and what if I don't what if I don't well
if I don't captain
what if I don't
are you not gonna let me damn it all
right all right I'll pick up my damn
toolbox fine
I got it captain now what do I do
do I get in the boat oh no
oh
um hello
hi welcome this is my baby
rough but this girl never let me down
once you are going quite deep in the
ocean so make sure to take care of her
uh there should be a big lint in one of
the walls oh
wow you'd think that you would have done
this beforehand captain
almost seems like
who I am wow never mind captain that was
fun
oh
I thought it was gonna be something nice
that is one big leak
gaping one might say
[Music]
good work they're no limit to the speed
all right
thanks captain
Let The Descent begin
it's beautifully done Lexi and
beautifully done incredible even
wow
oh my God look at this stunning
[Music]
incredible
I love it
oh wow
wow
damn damn
Unity
I mean I'm an Unreal Engine man myself
never made a game I've never made a game
before I've never made a game
maybe I'll do that someday maybe I'll
just do a 24-hour live stream where I'll
just see if I can make a game
at the end of it and then publish
whatever that is just to get the
Mystique out of the way so many people
are probably like oh man you've been
playing horror games for all you
probably could make a good one I was
like I bet I can't but I bet I can make
and games
foreign
[Music]
thanks captain
oh that's probably not good
[Music]
I'll fix this and keep my baby safe okay
thanks Captain I'm on it don't worry
about a thing captain
I'm on it can I light light
[Music]
once the depth reached at the bottom
oh
I'm preemptively
you can't ever damage this ship
this is my baby
oh no you oh no you don't
oh no you don't
take that
I can't seem to turn the lights on so
I'm assuming that I don't have to do
anything about that
I got you
don't worry babe I got you hope I don't
have to go into the engine room
not today
not hello God okay so maybe there might
have been
uh
run on today
you can't beat me in my hammering
abilities
[Music]
man I should make a movie about this
it's so
not today
captivating
whoa whoa what are you doing stop that
nope
I just welded that oh God there's water
on the floor
hey I want to know what's outside
who's out there no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no not today not today not
today
where was that no oh damn it
you know gold on hold on hold on
hold on
don't do it don't do it
cut it out
I'm I'm almost there at the bottom I
don't know what being at the bottom is
going to do for me I feel like that's
just going to be more of a problem
so
I don't think that there's any way for
me to get back up if uh I mean I kind of
know how this goes
yeah you go down to the ocean floor and
things don't go too well for you
ah
no
I heard another one no
there it is it's not at the front is
there is there another one
don't do it why do I hear another one oh
really
I'm almost there I think wherever there
is I don't think salvation lies in the
bottom of the ocean
oh
my finger's getting tired my hammering
finger
almost there
stop stop
hey I'm dead
I drowned in a puddle that deep
can you hear me yes what is happening
you tell me well
oh that's not good
[Music]
I don't think
okay
if it takes too long it will kill me I'm
taking too long oh right I mean I
thought I was trying to move
I probably shouldn't take that long next
time okay
well what about me
thank you Captain over
I should have let it kill me then and
there I should have let it kill me on
the way
they're in that tutorial I should have
let it
[Music]
oh oh this is still gonna be a thing oh
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do oh what are you gonna do oh are you
gonna be a grumpy are you gonna be a
grumpy goose
[Music]
I think it was a grumpy
well that's not good
all right fine
I'll play the game you want me to play
oh
so what happens if I flash when he's not
there I can't oh God oh my God
thank you
oh
are you there are you there
Oh Captain can you pull up faster
you go oh God I heard oh let's get out
of here
captain
's outside the ship captain
Captain
um
I I'm just kind of curious why you
couldn't pull me up as I was falling
down
you care about your baby so much
[Music]
I suppose not
oh really
Oh I thought I was done
[Music]
okay Captain I'm trying my best
I just wish you could have built your
baby a little sturdier
given that it holds already on the way
up or when they was up before
by the way Captain do I get paid for
this
oh God oh God
oh you're
chimney Germany
Germany
Germany Christmas I was literally every
wall segment possible if this monster
was smart it would have attacked the
same spot twice but it's an idiot and
I'm
just too clever for you is there a
punishment for hitting the wrong window
is it gonna try to trick me
is the captain gonna be like Oh no
you're falling again oh God I hear that
wait I hear that oh my God
oh stop it stop it stop
where are you where are you I hear that
I heard that was that just grumbling on
the outside or was that something I
should worry about
it so we'll see is I'm just gonna swing
the hammer I'm gonna hit right in the uh
in the glass and I think that's gonna
spell the end for me actually now that I
think about it why wouldn't the
why wouldn't the creature just aim for
the glass it's looking right in
it's pretty obvious where it should be
oh God
[Music]
is he just not thinking about it is it
just polite
or is the glass just stronger than any
of the metal around here
go away
oh my God oh my God oh God
[Music]
no
come on
oh my god really oh my god oh I hear it
I hear it no I thought I heard it hold
on
hold on
captain
did we make it
[Music]
Oh Captain
your baby
well at least I'm alive hey Captain
oh
where's my baby
sorry what did you
do oh
[Applause]
[Music]
God
no
Captain overboard I'm gonna kill you
oh where was I planning to go
on dog never mind
to the Briney deep with me
God
I love it 10 out of ten ten thousand uh
ten thousand hundred out of hundred what
happened to the cat
no
what happened to the cat
where's the cat
where's
[Music]
where's the cat
where's that
oh Ruby
is there a new game
game
I love me a hard mode
[Music]
wait hold on one more thing not only am
I gonna do that but also
I'm gonna play the game in Portuguese oh
[Music]
extrasion
now
um foreign
I know
it is
[Music]
to everyone
I will not be stopped
hey rookie no
to the sub downstairs we're almost there
let's be quick before someone else
arrives damn it
Captain esquito
utilize a double wall ah
hello
I am never sorry for anything I've ever
done
I will never apologize
[Music]
Kitty what are you doing out here did I
not see you before oh you're so
Portuguese
all right
ah Captain over all right I'm gonna beat
this on hard mode and I'm ready for
an extended ending yeah the game was
Elysian was acting like it was
oh God like it was gonna be tougher off
oh God
well I just had to open my
big fat guy
strategy ultimate strategy
what I do is I leave them partially
healed
so that when they break and need a
welding
they're easier to fix
it's the ultimate strategy can't
possibly go wrong
[Music]
especially the ones over there because
they'll never break
huh
uh-huh uh-huh oh my God I'm so smart
and now this is easier to fix oh my God
I got the strategy oh my God I'm a
genius
oh my God I'm so smart I am so smart oh
my God I'm smart
that's how we do it that's how we do it
oh my God I'm a genius oh my God and
you're gonna be easy
[Music]
easy oh not easy never mind not easy
not easy not easy not easy not easy
oh God oh God oh God oh God
oh I'm slower when it's deeper oh God
that's not good that's not what you want
I made it
oh I'm the best what is happening
[Music]
you know buddy I have a red hammer you
have beautiful red eyes
[Music]
take that
all right I have the strategy the
strategy is so simple
so simple it's almost too simple
I'll bring your baby back alive
Jesus Christ
gravity
holy crap oh my God why
this is quite impossible oh God
he was at the window turns out he was at
the window turns out he was at the
window
all right not today no
no no
oh my God I hear you no I do not you
guys were both already
oh my God are you kidding me
oh are you kidding me oh my God no no no
oh my God are you serious you serious
how and how
how
oh my god get fixed
get fixed oh
it fixed
get fixed
oh my God I'm close almost there
just gotta hold on a little longer baby
oh no no no no
I heard that
[Music]
I'm alive
I hear you
no
oh God I'm doomed
come on
this extended ending give me the
expected ending tell me what happened to
the cat
kitty kitty please
Kitty
where are you Kitty
[Music]
I don't know where's my baby
um
foreign
[Music]
but what about the extended ending
the after credit sequence
my God
hmm well that's peculiar
um
this is going to roll right into Damien
I know it I just know it all right okay
um Captain
you here somewhere
uh
[Music]
this seems
odd
oh Kitty hi there you are you survived
you're so smart now are there two of you
or did you just make your way uh down
there
uh before after before I went down after
I saw you the first time okay whatever
bye Kitty stay safe there's probably
some horrible things on this island
if I know my uh deserted Islands they're
usually horrible
oh
ah
[Music]
uh huh
I'm flying am I flying now did I just
descend into the sky and
yeah
what's that
oh no
wacky wavy inflatable arm flailing poop
man
the Lord the Lord
God the Lord
the Lord you could make a movie out of
this you can make a movie out of this
maybe I'll make a movie out of this
yes
okay
puramente cosmetico which probably means
that it's extremely better and vastly
more effective
[Music]
perfect
have I unlocked an extra Ultra difficult
mode all right maybe not
well anyway that was sinking iron
a game by Lexia well done lexan thank
you so much for making it
um you obviously didn't make it just for
me but I'm gonna pretend like you did
and I think you made it for the people
and for the members of your YouTube
channel so everyone please go support
Lexi and if you didn't know which I'm
sure you did
he has a YouTube channel he streams
regularly and makes games like this and
also edits my videos so thank you for
being on my team and helping out with
everything and just being an all-around
great guy I swear I'm gonna go to
Portugal someday
probably sooner than you think but thank
you if you want to play this game for
yourself and unlock the super ultra
secret ending
play through the link in the description
below and then leave a comment to show
your support thank you and as always I
will see you in the next video
and if you want to check out the trailer
for iron long for the movie check it out
bye-bye